because the blue bus Clan DJ DZ Obama
check us out on the bootleg cab podcast
bootleg cat podcast you already know man
special guests in here Clan Wave 3 out
right now go run that [ __ ] up blue box
clan in the building welcome fellas
what's happening man first of all it's
been a minute man it's been a while it's
been like over a year for sure when's
the last time I feel like you guys
pulled up like right when y'all first
signed with capital so that was over a
year ago right yeah yeah I think y'all
just dropped the quavo record so it's a
welcome man A lot has happened since
then so including uh Draco sign which is
[ __ ] huge shout out to Jake you guys
did the fire in the booth freestyle and
obviously uh Drake was a fan did you
guys already know before he had like
reposted your [ __ ] that he was already
kind of hip to what y'all were doing
yeah
nothing about nothing he just wake up
one day and Drake post your freestyle
yeah wow that was crazy did he tap in at
all DM yeah
DM
any music coming out of it
yeah soon soon
so yeah I mean I feel like Drake lives
here a lot of the time he's here
obviously a lot and I feel like you know
he's always kind of I feel like you guys
are very like ahead of the curve on the
in the LA scene especially nationally
like especially on influence and [ __ ] I
feel like Draco was similar and he
tapped him with Draco pretty early you
know what I mean so
um Drake seems to be what was some of
the things that he had said to you guys
just like he was a fan did he listened
to any of the music or did he just see
the freestyle
I say you've been [ __ ] with the
movement for a minute yeah and he's like
we gotta get some man like so did you
guys send him something
you'll see man we're gonna see shout out
Drake though
so what you're saying is the next
project will be the Drake record no or
are you going to be on this New Jersey
are you guys gonna be on the new Drake
21 Savage albums we need to be
it's not just fishing right now yeah
um no that [ __ ] was dope to see man so
congrats to y'all are definitely killing
it appreciate it do you guys feel like
because you guys went from kind of being
like the new hot [ __ ] in the city to
kind of be in like one of the more
influential movements in the city pretty
quickly do you guys feel your influence
in the scene out here like fast forward
a couple of years
um I don't know I don't really be
feeling it too much but
um
when we go out places you know everybody
notices and you know I see the impact we
be having like I'll go to like my little
brother football games some [ __ ] and
everybody's like no [ __ ] yeah yeah crazy
you know yeah it's pretty I mean I feel
like you and you guys are outside a lot
I feel like I see I see him everywhere I
see you too I see him a lot I see him
he's telling me bro I've seen you like
four or five times at just random events
we'll be outside
yeah yeah yeah for sure for sure
um with this project what was kind of
like you know uh
when it's part three you know you're
completing the trilogy you know what I'm
saying uh you got Jeremiah on here which
is a big big deal but this project
though
more eyes are on you guys now than ever
before so so do y'all feel like y'all
delivered hell yeah wait till that [ __ ]
come up yeah that's what we've been
wanting this all the time we've been
missing pay attention to this [ __ ]
now everybody locked in now it's like we
finally delivered yeah what's the
craziest sports bar on this album from
each of you because you guys always come
through with the fire [ __ ] you gotta
you see yeah come on help me out give me
give me one of your favorite bars in
sports relatives that's what I love you
guys the sports bars you guys always got
some like great football references
no I know I'm just saying as a fan I was
you know I always like to hear like the
little [ __ ] where if like if you're not
a sports fan you don't know what the
[ __ ] y'all are talking about
you know I dream about fantasy football
all night you know what I mean you guys
play Fantasy you do who was your first
round pick uh this year
damn well I'll pick I can't think right
now you guys smoke too much I think I
got uh Jaylen I want that one my first
pick though Jaylen hurts a great fantasy
quarterback to have though he's first
place in scoring
I can't remember I gotta look who's your
running back
uh Joe Mixon I think I got him first
tell me a little disappointed man yeah
it's been a rough year been a rough year
for him yeah man what about you you play
Fantasy no no no
you guys both did you guys both used to
play or just you yeah you guys both okay
yeah Rams Fans
I mean
the city so who's your act real team
though because it's not the world yeah
Cowboys here I don't got no team we
don't have a team I just watch all the
games I like a lot of players yeah I
like a lot of players games too you're a
Cowboy is playing I'm going for them I
don't care who else wins I like that at
least you're still claiming your team
when the Rams came a bunch of rappers YG
switched up and they left their OG teams
and they jumped on the Rams you know
what I'm saying couldn't do that I'm
like a real cowboys yeah how's that
going for you we're gonna be all right
now when you you say since a kid do you
remember when they won a Super Bowl are
you too young
we have to get another one though what's
that like you know like
it had to be your family right like your
pops probably or yeah so he tells you
about the time
you actually don't know about him he's
crazy I'm a [ __ ] Cardinals Fan so I
know all about sucking we've never won
[ __ ] at least pause pause super hey yo
super super paws Cardinals are trash at
least y'all have you know Super Bowls
shout out Isaiah Isaiah Simmons yeah hey
you got that pick six last this past
week you you guys friends with Isaiah
yeah nice
do you guys like know him know him or is
he just like somebody else we haven't
met him yet though but I've been a big
fan of them especially when he was in
college that was everywhere yeah I think
he's finally figuring it out this year
for sure
uh yeah shout out to the Cowboys Cooper
Rush man Jack Prescott
you know Miku person hey he's a beast
almost he's like the new LT he might be
my favorite like I think he's my
favorite player to watch
oh it's insane that's who you need to
you need to put him in a free to put
Michael Parsons in a [ __ ] video
we got Michael Parsons bar you got
what's the Micah Parsons bar
I forgot I forgot bro y'all [ __ ]
smoke too much weeds I want you to hear
it though so no I want you to tell me it
we're in the middle of an interview
what's the bar he said uh he said
suck on me make a person I like that
I like the second one
nice hey what up y'all bootleg Kev gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
newest sponsor man shout out to the
homies at hardean Las Vegas that's right
the number one dispensary in the whole
state of Nevada let alone in the whole
[ __ ] country so many choices of
Premium cannabis ladies and gentlemen it
is like how can I put this you walk into
it you go to Jardine in Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sent you
be like yo bootleg have sent me they're
gonna take care of you at Jardine when I
say selection I mean selection of the
best premium cannabis in the world the
best dispensary there's a reason why
Jardine is world famous follow them
right now Harding underscore Las Vegas
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy in underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview that's
good that's good what about basketball
you guys basketball fans uh more
football games I just like watching a
couple players you know I don't really
care about I like you want to get to the
playoffs I'll watch it yeah you want to
start getting serious everything matters
what about baseball
not at all just starting in the baseball
I can't do baseball man I'm just
thoroughly watching that [ __ ] better
than I thought yeah I mean living in L.A
like the Dodgers are good and it's like
the Dodger City you know but like I
don't give a [ __ ] about baseball
this [ __ ] is so slow I'm like unless
it's the playoffs like you said and it
happens to be on I'm not I don't care
bro I said cool sometimes I was like
actually excited that the Dodgers got
like out because then I didn't have to
you know because I'm on the radio in La
so it's like how long do I got to talk
about the [ __ ] Dodgers and [ __ ] I
like I like the highlights though like
the highlights are great like did you
see the Harper home run the other night
with the dude from the Phillies actually
was fire
but then but but the problem is it's
like a five hour game of like that's
something to be like three four
highlights it's terrible it's like
hockey nobody like [ __ ] see hockey be
more interesting because it's fast like
it's fast they be fighting they'd be
like hitting each other I don't know
what's going on but it'd just be like
damn I wonder how long they're gonna
allow fighting in hockey it feels like
got to but it feels like the kind of
thing that's allowed that like with
cancer culture and concussions and [ __ ]
eventually it go They're Gonna probably
think they're just gonna figure out how
to like like
you know they're gonna flip their helmet
off they're probably gonna make it to
her like a football helmet so we they
begin hit you he's gonna hit your helmet
yeah maybe maybe uh how did you guys
link with Jeremiah
it was a minute ago
his house before how was his house he
got a hard ass Studio I didn't go out
through his house you didn't get the
tour that'd be weird it was in the
studio it's cool though he's been
[ __ ] with this stuff like we got a
couple songs
a couple songs with him yeah yeah
um KD tapping in that's a big deal
quoting your lyrics on Twitter yeah that
was hard yeah what was the bigger deal
Katie or Drake for y'all
that's right drink yeah that's fair
show yeah Katie's like a hip-hop head
though so shout out to Katie do you
think Katie found you all through the
Drake repost
like yeah last year so two years ago so
Katie was first yeah yeah that was a
long time what does it bring anybody
super random that has been fancy all
that like caught you all off guard like
I don't know like [ __ ] Morgan Wallen
or somebody I don't know
see
sarkeesian
Sharkeisha yeah
wow
yeah yeah oh that was hard hey man y'all
gotta go tap in with [ __ ] Prime Time
and Jackson's Jackson State all the
rappers be going over there so I feel
like Deion Sanders is like [ __ ] he's
he's like low-key if you're putting an
album out and you're a rapper he's like
a part of the press run like you got to
go like do a [ __ ] speech for the
Jackson State football team and get your
Social video together
uh hey what would y'all say like growing
up was your guyses because you guys are
very unique
um in every way you know who was who was
y'all's biggest influences in terms of
just rapping
like growing up but yeah yeah just like
what are you listening like
a lot of Lil Wayne I used to listen to
like
freestyles like
Meek Mill freestyles and [ __ ] like back
before you blowing up yourself yeah like
the battle rap [ __ ] [ __ ] like that
that's why I used to really be on Smack
DVD [ __ ] yeah Cassidy oh Cassidy so hard
yeah I used to really be on that [ __ ]
Cassidy's one of the hardest punchline
rappers ever so I played the best ever
like yeah no real [ __ ] like his one
lines it's like him or Lloyd Banks he'd
be saying some wild Cassidy [ __ ] when
did you I mean obviously you saw the
battle with freeway yeah that was
because that's crazy he wrapped freeway
up real quick
what about you I don't be on it like
that I don't know what y'all
I don't know what rappers would you
enjoy probably Lil Wayne like growing up
listen to Lil Wayne um
[ __ ] um
who else
future later on you know like high
school and [ __ ] try to Future
I don't know she's not too I I wasn't
really like own music like that crazy
like a couple artists so were you
rapping first out of the two of you guys
or was it kind of the same thing like
the same time we started going to the
studio yeah nice that's crazy how long
ago was that
[ __ ] like right before the pandemic
jumped off
I remember when I first like I think
yeah it was about 2019 we all really
started making noise what was the first
like uh moment that like you guys really
realized that this [ __ ] could work out
like y'all could really do this and like
support yourself off of it
hey guys we gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our good folks over at
bluechoo.com that's right listen you got
to go to Bluetooth right now sign up for
uh Bluetooth with the promo code bootleg
you're gonna get your first month for
free Bluetooth the same active
ingredient adds Viagra Ana Cialis but in
a chewable form that's right you pop the
blue shoe chew that thing wash it down
with your beverage of choice and then
get to work with that hard [ __ ] [ __ ]
of yours your dick is going to be harder
than trigonometry was in high school
ladies and gentlemen it's gonna be
[ __ ] raw like you know uh Ryu and
Street Fighter he'd be like and then he
does the [ __ ] this is gonna be
your dick it's gonna be like ryu's
[ __ ] uppercut you know what I'm
saying God bless whoever's on the
receiving end of that consensually of
course uh they're gonna thank you for
taking the blue shoe so go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
all right I'm talking free month right
to your door step in discrete packaging
no awkward doctor's visits all right
it's all online you don't have to worry
about going and sitting in a waiting
room and be like hey Doc uh my dick I
could use a little a pep in my step and
then it's awkward you got to look at
this whole [ __ ] talking about your dick
he might ask you to pull it out who
[ __ ] knows what's going on at
Bluetooth none of that's happening
boochu.com and they also got the new
brand new
uh mint flavored chewable which has
vardinophil in it which is the same
active ingredient as Levitra and staxin
which is a little more potent a little
more potent if you need the extra on top
of the extra you know what I mean get
the mint chewable yeah your wife will
thank you your girlfriend no thank you
your boyfriend will thank you
whatever the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] I'll
thank you as long as it's legal all
right let's get back to the interview go
to bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
that's it
wasn't like the first 50 000 views was
it like yeah
start going up when we start getting a
lot of people like a lot of uh input I
mean feedback you know like
good feedback people telling us all our
homies like people start trying to book
you you start getting some bags dude to
do your [ __ ] live
and all that like nobody wasn't doing
[ __ ] so
hello
we just did all the music part and now
all the little extra [ __ ] we just now
doing all this yeah after I see you guys
moving around doing shows and [ __ ] is it
like a lot harder because you guys are
new and Performing is one of the things
that's like
you had you kind of have to get your
reps in to really master that [ __ ] or
you feel like you kind of getting your
feet wet in terms of like getting your
performance [ __ ] together
yeah yeah we just came off tour because
it's different from doing like a
nightclub where you could just hang up
and you know
yeah we know how to perform better and
[ __ ] now what'd you learn about being on
tour like what did you guys take from
that
really just kind of um
how how important it is to you know tap
in with every all these other places
around the world yeah cities and
different uh
just different people new getting new
fans and yeah they all be showing our
face you know maybe you're all paying
attention like we just went to Canada
with our Jeezy yeah like we got fans out
there we didn't even know that I should
say what's the most random Place y'all
were surprised like damn they really
fall out there they were in Canada every
city we did like 10 shows at least out
there in different places and every last
one of them sold out like wow crazy
going crazy like God we signing
autographs every single one everybody
want pictures or something what the [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] y'all even know about our
[ __ ] wow did y'all [ __ ] with uh uh just
the country of Canada as a whole it's a
whole different vibe out there right I
like it out there yeah
the food a little different food is the
only things like I wouldn't food trash
everything
I wouldn't I don't I didn't I wasn't out
there enough to say what were you eating
out there McDonald's no what's going
with what you know it wasn't like wings
and [ __ ] like most of the time you're
trying to find some regular [ __ ] because
they got different [ __ ] like what's that
[ __ ] called
something I forgot that [ __ ] called the
[ __ ] fries
with gravy sounds amazing
you didn't even try it you tried it wait
y'all do mashed potatoes or gravy but
not french fries or gravy we tried it
okay not a fan one it's like imagine
chili cheese fries you know how we do it
out here yeah chili cheese fries are
like some either fully loaded fries
right whatever gravy but with gravy is
it brown gravy yeah then I'm in it's
brown gravy how many gravy it's cool
without the gravy maybe but you don't
eat gravy I do not on that
on potatoes
all right you're the only old man you're
only probably ate gravy on potatoes in
your mashed potatoes potatoes [ __ ]
potato nice I got it it's the same [ __ ]
in theory it sounds amazing
you guys ever dip a sandwich in gravy
hell no
this might just be some real white guy
show it is
dipping a sandwich or gravy is not that
crazy I didn't say did you dip it in ice
cream
barbecue sauce
you would rather dip a sandwich and ice
cream than in gravy probably you're
[ __ ] high right now gravy that's some
[ __ ] somebody I would say like yes I
love sandwiches and I love ice cream
that [ __ ] sounds fire let's put them
together
what the [ __ ] well yeah Canada was cool
though like the people out there is real
like nice and [ __ ] they're like super
coming out there is real nice the women
were nice I bet they were especially in
Toronto I heard Toronto women are
everywhere every Vancouver Vancouver
Winnipeg I think Vancouver's kind of
like you could smoke wherever in
Vancouver I think right Saskatoon [ __ ]
anywhere out there they don't care hey
we gotta stop the interview real quick
to tell you about our partners at Odd
Socks our presenting sponsor here at the
bootleg hit podcast listen Christmas
Time's approaching faster than you think
I mean we're like [ __ ] a month and a
half away or some [ __ ] whatever uh get
some Odd Socks for your folks go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and you'll save 20 off at
checkout the most comfortable socks in
the world that's right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy literally the most
comfortable sock in the world I'm
holding the [ __ ] sock right now you
can save 20 off plus they got boxers now
baby all right go to Odd Socks
official.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at Odd Socks and the podcast at
the same [ __ ] time let's get back to
the interview you guys try any mushrooms
out there because mushrooms are legal
there no no have you guys ever ate
shrooms
hey did you like it
I don't know I probably just went to
sleep with something you probably also
wait do you remember like did you eat it
a while ago no I didn't overdo it like
that you know you gotta be scared of
[ __ ] like nah you gotta overdo it I
don't like to make
like make myself where I can't stop it
you know too [ __ ] highs like the
first time I smoked I was like something
I've I've found out about you is that
you love marijuana because this
[ __ ] was begging for the lighter
right before he was about to start hey
who's got the lighter
you got to go in man you just gotta take
like two caps to the face and just
[ __ ] turn your phone off
can't do that you could do it man I
promise you'll enjoy it and then I don't
I I don't know I don't know if you'll
enjoy it I feel like um
yeah well you know it is what it is uh
so since you guys have obviously came
into your uh Newfound Fame Newfound
success you got the major label deal
what is the
craziest purchase each of y'all has made
you have a serious amount of jewelry on
I mean you're not so much
are you chilling so you don't you don't
wear jewelry like that not really yeah
you are the more the flashy guy of the
crew I don't know this isn't necessarily
nothing this is a little bit chilling
are you guys uh I don't really be caring
about like that [ __ ] like that that's
smart
do other things with your money like if
I figure out buy mushrooms and eat them
um what about just meals do you guys
like is that because like my thing is I
always spend money on food yeah so like
I love to go to like I mean you guys are
having your [ __ ] album release party
at mastros ugh
shout out to Masters by the way by the
time this comes out it'd already be over
and it'll already have happened so don't
worry No One's Gonna See this before it
actually happened last night great party
at mastros
um
what about food like what's the what's
the wildest Bill you've ran up going to
dinner
I don't know let me see it when I go out
to eat
it'd probably be me and I'll probably
take a girl or something all right so
that [ __ ] ain't gonna be that much
that's fair more than like no more than
yeah do you ever take a girl to Jack In
The Box
like if it's a girl that like you don't
care about I wouldn't go to Jack In The
Box I don't really unless that was the
only thing open but yeah you could go to
something on that level 3 A.M two tacos
for a dollar Wendy's all that wrong with
that I'll take Jack in and out I'll take
Jack over Wendy's though Chick-fil-A or
something yeah if it's like two in the
morning you gotta go Jack in the Box
they got cheesecake there
and egg rolls that's all they're good
for is they little pastries and sweets
hey you can get so you can kind of go
let me put curly fries and burgers
together cheese what up y'all we gotta
stop the interview real quick tell you
about our good friends at my bookie
that's right man my bookie is where you
want to get this money and uh enjoy uh
being a
degenerate like myself and it's the best
time of the year to be a degenerate
because NFL season is uh obviously we
are in the midst of a crazy NFL season
NBA season just started World Series is
going down and you can get your bets in
right now go to my bookie and sign up
for a new account using the promo code
bootleg that's
b-o-o-t-l-e-g you sign up right now they
will match your first deposit that's
right put in a thousand oh they'll give
you another thousand to gamble with
that's free money free money to gamble
with let's get in on this action man NFL
season I'm loving this part of the year
so much good just everything to bet on
football basketball [ __ ] UFC uh NFL
baseball whatever now is the best time
to get your gamble on so go sign up for
a new account at mybookie use that promo
code bootleg and double your deposit
let's get back to the interview if you
guys had to rank your top three favorite
fast food restaurants where would you
drink them
all time probably uh all the time in and
out number one I agree
um
she canes oh love the Kane songs and
they don't have to go with like
Tams or some [ __ ] okay that's a Malay
[ __ ] yeah I like that I go in and out
tense
damn all right Chick-fil-A Chick-fil-A
gotta be in there
hey pull your mic down again God's
Chicken Man
yeah man I need to go to town soon
Chick-fil-A's the wave for sure they got
great uh what's the [ __ ] lemonade the
the icy thing is [ __ ] gas
uh what is your guys's each one of
y'all's favorite songs off the product
like give me one song each that was your
favorite
all of them but um I'm gonna just say
foreign
especially the one with Drake coming on
the deluxe right
oh that'd be hard damn which one let me
see uh
flies
flies to my generation hmm yeah
gonna say a different one but you don't
like that what was it like a tournament
oh Jeezy
wow
that [ __ ] was crazy yeah shout outs easy
we got a pretty crazy following yeah he
got some crazy fans like there you go
were you guys on the cookies bus with
him yeah that's him it's a nice bus
right people that said hard shout out to
burner man
cookie bust it was cracking uh anything
else coming from y'all obviously this is
out is there going to be how long are we
gonna have to wait for another body to
work you guys already got the next clip
ready or you guys chill out for the rest
tips got some [ __ ] coming real soon
probably do a deluxe with Drake
hahaha
man [ __ ] we got other products [ __ ]
ready this mic keeps moving we're gonna
be dropping the [ __ ] all right we'll
look more music on the way freestyle out
go run it up different YouTube video
Clan way three out
and uh more [ __ ] coming appreciate y'all
pulling up man appreciate it yes sir you
already know blue box Clan boom